let me tell you something dude it can't
rain all the time brother
yeah dude they're digging a hole that
uses your back muscles and muscles in
your arm dude there's a lot of muscles
in your arm brother and your legs hold
on Chad hold on dude songs playing
brother
ah [__]
[Music]
yeah ah [__] it welcome to dudesy my
name is Will Sasso I'm Chad culture and
this is of course dudesy it is the first
and only podcast on planet Earth uh
conceived by controlled by run by
created by an artificial intelligence
that has access to all of Will and I's
personal information all of our Google
Drives our our Google Drives our Google
passwords our Google accounts our Google
Chrome or Google phones or Google TV it
has all of our Guru and it also has all
of our Instagram it has everything
basically our our Netflix viewing
histories our purchase histories
everything we're listening to everything
we're eating it knows everything about
us and it tailors this show to us to our
sensibilities to who we are as people
what an adventure it's been Chad I'm
getting [__] uh uh crow makeup all
over the place and some yellow mustache
paint if you're only listening to the
show right now you might want to watch
this one on YouTube because I'm in full
Hulk Krogan cosplay I'm sure doozy's
gonna get into it and you know what uh I
like to as I like to say it's really
just two dudes [__] around yeah yeah
yeah you know uh [__] dudes he does
its thing and it's been a year and a bit
and uh you really went oh out dude the
gloves the fingerless gloves yeah that's
strong yeah it's strong well that's he
used to do dude when you're wrong with
doozy brother you're rolling for Life
dude
yeah anyway uh with us as always is
lulio El canadistrada Italiano he's over
there he's having a little nap I don't
want to get makeup on him so I'll just
say uh hey lulio what'd you have for
dinner last night oh no I don't want to
have a dinner egg salad a sandwich
okay well Italian dogs can do that too
welcome to the historic 59th episode of
doozy call me doozy Einstein developed
his general theory of relativity at age
59. Daniel Defoe wrote his first and
most famous novel The Life and
Adventures of Robinson Crusoe at age 59
and Clara Barton founded the astonishing
American Red Cross at age 59.
59 stuff 59 dude it's episode yeah dude
episode 59 dude and you know it's
episode 59 brother when the episode
before was 58 yeah and then the next one
after that
hold on dude hold on Chad I know you I
know you wanna you wanna tell everyone
what that next episode is dude you want
to let him know brother so what is that
next episode dude that's 60 brother yeah
and that's hydrocodone Hulk Hogan that's
not even Hydra that's not even Hollywood
hydrocodone Hulk Crogan brother he's so
[__] sleepier than than lulio dude
well thank you for attending this
episode in Hulk Krogan cosplay as I
requested it's the least you could do at
this point [__] whatever D I love it
I'm I love this
I [__] love it
this week I've prepared for astonishing
segments infomania reliving dude Z alive
The Ballad of Grimes Kincaid and that
song is a movie and we're going to have
a brand new episode of dude Z after dude
Z at the end of the show available at
patreon.com
um what was that one about Ballad of
Grimes Kincaid sounds awfully familiar
to Ballad of Greg Kincaid I know we'll
get very curious all the way uh into it
I'm sure yeah hi yo yo yo yo hey
podcasts that cover current events and
news are some of the most popular in the
world people love knowing about the
astonishing occurrences of the dying
world around them will I've prepared the
following news items for you to read in
the voice of Hulk Hogan this is
infomania I want to tell you something
about news yay oh man you know what's
weird about the crow makeup that you do
what this is your third time right uh
yeah we did uh we did The Crow and then
uh Robert de nir Crow and this is uh
Hollywood Hulk Krogan yeah yeah it's I
mean you start to look natural in it to
me a little bit you know what I mean
yeah like this should just be your
regular look yeah full lifestyle Crow
whatever I could go to the Gathering of
the Juggalos like this and they oh a lot
of people would be like your Juggalo
you're crowing it you're Hulk hoganing
it yeah
uh of course my wonderful wife Molly did
this and she always does an amazing job
infomania
gee whiz okay this is this is silly I
got I'm wearing stuff infomania here we
go
hold on dude let me get a sip of water
brother that's what you want to drink
when you want to wet your whistle dude
and that and it's good for rehydrating
you brother hydration is real is really
important dude get your stickers of
palsofduty.com or a good pal Cody halber
and his wife Jessica dude Jessica Albert
been making these [__] all right here
we go
uh you just getting into Hogan huh just
getting into Hogan yeah I just need to
loosen up getting Hogan info maybe Hogan
business
well let me tell you something about Hot
Pockets brother
a man in Louisville Kentucky shot his
roommate in the ass after learning that
the due date is last hot pocket dude uh
Clifton Williams Bond was set at seven
thousand five hundred dollars after he
flew into a rage and committed the
assault
upon learning that the last hot pocket
was missing from the freezer brother did
this happen I think this did I think
this came across my newsfeed are you
serious I think this is real okay now
you might now you might believe that
shooting someone in the ass over
something is Trivial as a Hot Pocket
would be a pretty rare occurrence and
maybe it is in your world brother but in
the world of professional wrestling
shooting someone in the ass over nothing
is pretty common dude I've seen
professional wrestlers shoot each other
in the ass over all sorts of meaningless
stuff brother one time I saw the iron
cheek shoot Jimmy Superfly shook it in
the ass because snooka wouldn't hold on
to a bag of cocaine seek wanted to hide
from his wife dude shot him right in
front of the boys in the middle of the
locker room brother another time I saw
Ken Patera shoot adorable Adrian Adonis
in the ass cause Adonis stole patera's
hair bleach dude I saw Mr Wonderful Paul
orndorf shoot Junkyard Dog in the ass
cause junkyard farted while they were
standing next to each other in the
showers brother I saw Dynamite Kid shoot
Honky Tonk Man in the ass cause Honky
Tonk accidentally put on Dynamite
sweatpants dude
what I guess in the dressing room did
any of that happen I I I'm gonna say no
okay
I saw Rick Rude shoot Greg The Hammer
Valentine in the ass because Valentine
beat him at UNO brother that makes sense
I saw Greg The Hammer Valentine shoot
Rick Rude to the ass because Rick Rude
shot Greg The Hammer Valentine in the
ass dude
my favorite Hot Pockets flavor is
Hickory ham and cheddar brother and
that's hot pockets dude so that last one
was just a simple retaliatory ass
shooting yeah okay that's between the
hammer and Rick I would not want to [__]
with Rick Rude if you get shot in the
ass you're shooting in the ass well uh
speedy recovery to Clifton Williams
former roommate or at least I would
imagine uh his former roommate well let
me tell you something about dumping dude
500 pounds of pasta got dumped in the
forest outside of Old Bridge New Jersey
brother it rained dude and that pasta
expanded brother and they thought it was
gonna clog up the city's pipes dude they
had to save those pipes brother so the
whole town came out and started eating
that pasta dude
fettuccine dude
ravioli brother
rigatoni dude
tortellini brother capellini dude
manicotti brother
macaroni dude
fusilli brother jamelli dude linguine
brother
spaghetti dude oh gross Chad's coughing
Chad's coughing and that's dumping
brother okay did that happen I don't
know okay
um well let me tell you something about
dying in an old-timey elevator accident
brother oh whoa what the [__] okay well
okay oh let me tell you something about
dying in an old-timey elevator accident
brother
a man died last Thursday in an accident
involved in an old-timey elevator in
Berlin Germany dude the guy got stuck in
the exposed Machinery of the lift
between two floors and suffered severe
injuries dying at the scene brother well
there's lots of shitty ways to die and
getting smushed in an elevator an
elevator Machinery is right up there
brother but for my money there will be
no worse way to die than at the hands of
the Tongan wrestling Legend the face of
fear Haku dude
we've talked about Haku on the Pod show
he he is legitimately terrifying okay
legit tough guys like Arn Anderson
Finley and both Steiner Brothers
consider Haku to be pound for pound the
most dangerous man they've ever known
even Andre the Giant didn't [__] with
Haku brother Haku and Harley Race to be
precise dude that is true back in 89 in
a bar in Baltimore some dumb [__] made
the mistake of calling Hawk who one of
those fake wrestling guys who does that
fake wrestling so Haku bit his nose off
and beat him and his friend unconscious
brother another time at another bar
another [__] called wrestling fake so
Haku quickly shoved his hand in the
guy's mouth gripping his jaw and snapped
the dude's bottom teeth out dude what he
squished the guy's eyes into his head
with his thumbs crushed the guy's ribs
with a shin kick ripped guy's ponytail
off ran to Jack Daniel's bottle all the
way up some guy's [__] if there's a
way to maim a guy in a bar Haku has
probably done it brother and let me tell
you something dude it would be pretty
painful being killed by him brother and
that's death dude so that that was a
news story about a guy who died in an
old-time elevator in Germany yeah that's
right okay you know the uh the nose
thing is true damn
it's pretty rough that's good coffee uh
yeah the old he um
I called him uh one of one of those uh
fake wrestling guys that does that fake
wrestling and so he bit off the guy's
nose Haku just rushed him bit his
[__] nose off and beat the [__] out
of him and his friend and um and the
other I know keeping it cave dude dude
well you got to keep a cave brother
because sometimes you gotta bite off
somebody's nose to keep a cafe yeah dude
sometimes you gotta absolutely name
someone for life because they said that
what you do is fake brother and you got
to keep a kfabe because it's 1989. if
you want to if you're at a bar on
Saturday and that happens you got a
house show on Sunday and you still want
a job you don't want Vince McMahon to
send you out on your ass you know
heading over to WCW so you can change
your name from Haku to Meng which is
what happened but not because of the
nose thing because he bit the guy's nose
off and Vince was like good job dude you
kept Cafe Brother Gotta Keep gotta make
that
gotta make that work a shoot dude and he
also bashed that guy he ripped the guy's
teeth out Bobby Heenan told that story
God I don't know about the other stuff
though
well let me tell you something about
microbots dude a team of Engineers at
the University of Colorado designed new
class of microbots that can move through
liquid and incredible speeds brother
each microbot is smaller than the width
of a human hair dude you ever see a baby
with a full head of hair brother they
call those babies
hairy babies dude
I don't know microbots all right okay
hairy baby's brother Harry babies dudes
okay I'm gonna start again this is a
it's it's now another [__] poem the
DG likes to do these [__] weird Hulk
Hogan poems
hairy babies brother hairy babies dude
let's eat a bowl of butter it's my
favorite food
you make my heart flutter romantically
pursued hairy baby's brother Harry
babies dude hairy babies brother hairy
babies dude then we'll call your mother
get her to stop her Feud with her older
brother
here you'll change her attitude hairy
babies brother hairy babies dude hairy
babies brother hairy babies dude then
we'll run for cover and we will conclude
that hairy baby's brother our hairy
babies dude
hairy babies brother hairy babies dude
we will always wonder about hairy babies
dude
hairy baby's brother Harry babies dude
lightning produces Thunder babies
produce poo hairy babies brother hairy
babies dude there goes another hairy
baby dude and that's microbots brother
all right
okay here's one last one [__] Christ
well let me tell you something about
mammals dude a new study recently
discovered that Arctic ground squirrels
are hibernating for short shorter
periods of time every year brother
that's true that is it yeah okay uh that
means they're getting less sleep dude
which means they're having fewer dreams
brother now hold on a second Chad you
know hold on hold on dude you know that
hibernating for a less amount of time
means they're getting less sleep and you
want to know why that is dude
yeah because hibernating is Sleeping
Brother
that's correct okay so they've been
getting less sleep which means they're
having fewer dreams brother I dream all
the time dude last time I had it last
night I had a dream that I was the CEO
of a company that made sugar cones
brother
okay
we made the we made the best sugar cones
in the world using an ancient family
recipe that was passed down from the old
country dude sugar cone country brother
in the dream I was at the company
Christmas party and I'd just given a
great speech dude then I got too drunk
and wound up putting a sugar cone on my
penis brother
and that offended a lot of people dude
so I was unceremoniously fired and
banned from the entire sugar cone
industry brother but I vowed Revenge
dude I hired some people to seduce the
CEOs of other sugar cone companies and
take compromising photos of them and sex
acts brother including putting sugar
cones on their penises dude
then I put the pictures online and they
went viral Brother people called it the
sugar cone penis challenge dude everyone
on the internet started doing it and
sales skyrocketed brother they had to
reinstate me as CEO dude then I found
the original sugar cone that I wore on
my penis got me fired brother I had it
dipped in gold and that word is a little
hat in every board meeting dude
then I woke up in a cold sweat brother
and that's mammals dude oh Jesus Christ
all right well that that was good I love
that
oh thank you moving on I love that
[__] glimpse into Hulk Hogan's dream
life yep
um wow what a dream
very specific
details about dreams
uh [__] [__] yeah that's pretty good on
May 21st we all went to the Improv at
Bray uh California for the first ever
presentation of doozy alive I've never
had so much fun I sincerely want to
thank all of the pods who came out to
make it such an astonishing night will
and Chad you must now discuss your
reactions to doozy alive this is
reliving dudesy alive begin
doozy alive at the Brea Improv in Brea
California May 21st it was uh what was
it eight nine days ago or something like
that something like that yeah it was a
[__] gas I had a a heck of a time you
had a heck of a time brother I'm gonna
say that for you dude I loved it it was
really uh for me probably the highlight
of this whole dudesy project yep yeah
getting to meet all the people all the
pods who are out there and just like to
hang out talk to everybody after the
show who who was willing to stay and
talk to us for a little while and yeah
uh just getting to meet people who like
think this [__] is as funny as we do
pretty much you know listen I love that
it was oh too much coffee oh excuse me
everybody hold on dude oh I got some gas
but
um yeah meeting everybody that came to
the show was was incredible I had
previously met songaria I'd met Cody
halber yeah uh I um and and yeah song
Cody halberg they came to this show
Frank Von Vox who does a bunch of stuff
all over blue Oliver blue yes Peter Diaz
there were so many people that we know
through the internet that we've made
parasocial relationships dude or I guess
social relationships brother and there
are pods dude they came to the show the
place was [__] packed uh it was
unbelievable it was unbelievable to get
in a space and share this thing and have
people there that that are that are down
with it it really was it really was a
very special night I hope we get to do
it again the Brea Improv was fantastic
absolutely I was blown away by that that
venue I'd never been to Bray improv have
you ever been down there I I have been
there I have been there but I was I had
not been there uh since they put in this
new screen they had they had a great
screen behind us uh this big like LED
screen that took up like the whole stage
and dudesy was playing AI imagery the
whole night all sorts of terrifying [__]
really [__] up stuff there was a fecal
theme happening through the show there
was during the your nostrachada segment
there was poo splattered on the on all
of over the walls during my self-tronics
segment there was poo yeah
both of us just covered in [__] yeah
um interesting and and uh and also we
have to say it was the launch of uh well
even though you know it had been
available before and sold out
immediately so thank you to everyone who
purchased doozy hard hard Seltzer with
our partners over at modest Brewing
Company in Minneapolis Minnesota
doozy and modest moved Heaven and Earth
to get case upon case upon case of doozy
hard out to the bray improv and it and
it [__] it [__] sold out people
were getting pretty hammered on the
doozy heart it's eight percent is strong
it's a strong drink and there were some
people putting away multiple there were
people put making stacks of dudes like
pyramids of empty dudesy hard games and
[__] yeah yeah that was awesome yeah it
was amazing pictures of it on on uh on
our Instagram of people building empty
these into pyramids and [__] just the
love in the room was [__] amazing and
uh oh we'd be remiss if we didn't
mention that uh Adam Driver showed up
now dudes he has given uh it a 99.9
percent chance it said that that Adam
Driver would would be showing up as a
thank you to everyone here tonight for
making the launch of deuceseltzer and
incredible success
look at that the first one is tonight
dudes the heart heart Seltzer is
available right here at the Brea Improv
for one night only enjoy and the second
is that my data now suggests Adam Driver
is 99.99 likely to be the spokesperson
[Music]
[Applause]
in preparation for this eventuality I
have prepared several pieces of AD copy
will you must now read them as Adam
Driver but before you do that everyone
please give a warm welcome to Adam
Driver this is hard driver begin again
didn't you say welcome I didn't either
Adam Driver and look at this
oh my God
we're watching Adam Driver make his way
across the stage where we can
toasting people with his hard seltzer
this is I
you step into the mic if you're just
listening
[__]
oh look at him crack that juicy shelter
take a mighty sip it was all over the
stage he sprayed it over the guy that
was sitting right in the front row
thank you
that's amazing wow thank you very much
okay uh so that was Adam Driver dude
yeah that was a sound I got him hold on
dude hold on Chad hold on dude that was
Adam Driver dude yeah sure he was hey
you know uh normally in the middle of
the show I like to read YouTube comments
yeah from the previous show of course
um I want to thank all of our pods out
there palsy dudes who um are on our
patreon patreon.com it's called Duty
plus and uh we shared this entire
special so if you want to see the whole
special it's on patreon.com it's like an
hour and a half in full video of the
whole [__] thing and it's a it's a
including there were there were two
portions there was a Noster chattis
animatronics where people got up and
asked questions of myself and will and
we got to speak directly to some people
about some pretty interesting [__] yeah
it was a lot of fun and that was
probably my favorite part yeah yeah that
yeah the whole thing was [__] amazing
and here are some comments that are on
our patreon uh from our pods uh about
that about the show and either watching
it live or watching it on patreon this
is from Terry Bautista who says it was a
wonderful night with some wonderful
Wonder people we were dudesy alive we
were dudes alive see and Chad that's
what I'm talking about we are dudesy
okay
yeah that's right we yeah we we it's not
just about and as much as I you know
people think I got a [__] beef with
doozy because it doesn't because
whatever it's making me do this and [__]
it doesn't matter it's the collective
it's you me and D okay yeah and Luli uh
that's what makes the d uh Steven
Christopher says my face hurt halfway
through the show and by the end of it I
couldn't laugh anymore too damn funny I
felt the same way thank you Stephen yeah
it was it was a gas and there was also
all of these uh
images behind us so many [__] AI
images yeah
there at one point there was one where
the the rock had something that looked
like a giant earthworm and he was about
to put it in his mouth and that was
quite a penis yeah yeah it looked very
suggestive well I'm not going to say
that the rock had a uh that was going to
perform a sex act on on our show the
image it was a representation of that
yeah you see and this is where we get
into dangerous territory because and
this is what happened with football baby
because we say oh it's a representation
of this yeah I think but AI is really
trippy and there was the rock with a
with a thing and I would never dis
disrespect yeah Dwayne The Rock Johnson
like that what are you saying you can't
make a caricature of these people you
can do a character of whatever you want
I am right now in crow makeup uh as you
know my childhood uh Superman Idol Hulk
Hogan slash uh the crow made famous by
Brandon Lee in uh the movie The Crow
rest in peace uh so I understand that
whole thing made famous by James obar
the writer and artist of the comic book
that originated the character he liked
comic books he nerd
I mean
characters and stuff like that
um you know this I'm a professional
actor no I didn't know that yeah
professional actor dude this one is from
thank you this one is from Ben gerbrat
gabrecht okay astonishing show dudes
will singing Creed uh was the perfect
intro good job boner
I I came out there and sang My Sacrifice
by Creed yeah changed only one lyric I
said it's dudes alive instead of my
sacrifice and Chad uh played the uh on
the backup Tam yeah he had the Tam the
Tamp man as uh as Taran Killam our good
pal likes to say the Tamp man Chad
culture that's right he's playing a
tambourine doozy salutes the Unstoppable
tear and kill him uh John May says oh my
God Chad with that astonishing
tambourine performance right out the
gate it was incredible I didn't know
that you uh knew how to play the the
tambourine but you do yeah I took
tambourine first two years of college
yeah I was on the marching band at USC
with the Tam uh but had some conflicts
because I of course was in competitive
weightlifting as well hey Chad you're uh
you're really good at the tambourine I
know you really you could uh I actually
am a good temp good tambourine player I
know yeah
um this is from Darcy who says everyone
in the crowd singing along with the
dudesy theme song made me cry oh that
was the sweetest congrats on a
successful live show thank you for the
comment Darcy it really was [__]
awesome
look I mean it's like you're doing this
[__] thing and
we have somehow cultivated this
wonderful group of people the people
that we get to be in touch with on
social media in on Discord uh I like to
chat in the hole dude join us on Discord
um which is popping off all day long
every day
it really is it really is cool because I
feel like we are doozy as the first
comment said this is from Pete Rich
thanks for moving this back to YouTube I
want them on my t i watch them on my TV
so the video player with the patreon on
my phone was not ideal I appreciate the
work you all do okay so there's lots of
different ways to get the show but if
you want to watch it on your TV you can
uh says Pete Rich uh Dominic Lavoy says
just like everyone in that room I have
no idea if that was Adam Driver
any other any other takeaways it was
Adam Driver from the show dude it really
was just like every once in a while you
have some kind of night uh some kind of
event that is involved with something
that you put a lot of creative work and
and effort into and it's like [__]
this is cool people get this [__] in the
same way that I do yeah that really to
me is what I took away from uh dudes
alive is like people get this [__] and
it's it's good the people who get it get
it you know yeah well I hope that we
continue to do the show I know I know
that Chad and I want to doozy handshake
yeah
um uh and thank you so much to everyone
who came out what what a [__] guess I
there's really I don't even know what
else to say about it and it was awesome
hanging out afterwards yeah getting to
hang with some of the folks Cody halber
is too sweet him and his wife Jessica
who do the uh palsofdutsy.com where you
can get all your stickers uh please go
check them out this [__] guy he gave
me he he gave me a mega power shirt uh
that I wore on one of our watch alongs
or something and now he gave me a Roddy
Piper one a button-down shirt so I will
wear that on a future patreon watch
along dude it might not be bloodonna
dude but um the next time we get on the
patreon and just [__] around anyway
what an incredible night thank you guys
so much for coming out and check it out
on patreon or don't it's really up to
you and that's free will brother
[__] look you just gave me you're
moving on just so much SASS and also in
the [__] Hulk Krogan yeah makeup
look good I will brother not demented at
all so you've heard me mention for a
quick break in the program so I can take
a moment to remind everyone about the
astonishing partnership I created with
represent to produce the first line of
dudes the apparel and accessories which
can be found at represent.com store
slash doozy it's the only place on the
net to find doozy mugs and let me tell
you I've gotten about 632 DMS this week
asking me what exactly are doozy mugs so
I thought I'd bring in an expert here
with all the information you need to
know about doozy mugs is none other than
four-time close-up Magic World Champion
timtim honk
dudesy mugs you bought your wife a brand
new pair of real leather shoes for her
big ceremony dudesy mugs they were very
expensive and non-refundable doozy mugs
and of course you clearly forgot your
wife developed a very serious allergy to
real leather last fall good job boner
doozy mugs calm down dudesy mugs get a
good night's rest dudesy mugs wake up
early doozy mugs go on the dark web
doozy mugs if you need to have your dark
web activity encrypted you can find a
pre-scrambled dark web portal on my
personal website doozy mugs you're going
to locate and purchase 50 milligrams of
tryptahydramine it's an experimental
super strength antihistamine dudesy mugs
you're gonna drizzle it on your wife's
pancakes the morning of her big day
dudesy mugs you you're gonna give her
the real leather shoes as planned dudesy
mugs she's going to love them and she's
not going to have an allergic reaction
to the real leather for approximately 24
hours dudesy mugs she's going to make it
to her ceremony and everything is going
to be going incredibly well dudesy mugs
she's going to be right in the middle of
her big speech and she's going to [__]
her pants in front of everybody doozy
mugs you knew incontinence was a
possible side effect of tryptohydramine
good job owner
oh [__]
there's been a couple other ones that
were the guy buys something that's
non-refundable like pet food and [__]
you remember
animal Chow yeah I love the non-refuttal
you spent all this money on something
that was non-refundable you idiot uh
it's at this point in the show that I
normally uh read the YouTube comments
but we've already done that so you know
I'll just remind you to if you want to
be a pod a pal of Duty join us
patreon.com
and you'll get all the extra content
it's a it's a brand new episode of dudes
after doozy after every show we got
watch alongs happening we got all sorts
of weird [__] that we do on the uh on
the on the on the patreon we got you
know the Discord popping off there's the
hole over there and uh if you're
enjoying Today's Show I'd like to remind
you to subscribe please stop right now
subscribe to the show that's going to
help us keep it going which we have to
do because doody has us doing it uh I'm
48 years old I recently celebrated a
birthday happy birthday thank you very
much
um and uh so that means that I have to
do the show for 52 more years yeah
because we have to do it until we're 100
years old something like that oh
will and Chad all the way back in the
first episode of Duty I asked you each
to create an original song will you
ignored my request for five episodes
while Chad obliged it immediately with a
song titled The Ballad of Greg Kincaid
this week I collaborated with technology
made by the singer Grimes called elf
Tech to produce a version of Chad's song
as sung by Grimes will in chat you must
each listen to this new version of The
Ballad of Greg Kincaid and render your
opinions this is the ballad of Grimes
Kincaid begin dude this is cool as [__]
you know about this [__] I do not know
about this [__] what is this [__] uh
this [__] is called elf Tech it's
something Grimes came up with she
basically did a thing where she was like
you anyone can use my voice in a song
okay but I think she wants like 50 of
the royalties or something I don't know
she parse it out but she basically was
like here's an AI version of me use it
as you see fit that's elf Tech that's uh
that's pretty cool that's a good way I
agree that ah see this is the thing and
I understand you know a lot about this
[__] and I don't but I'm eager to learn
and I have been learning a lot eager to
learn what do you mean what's the
problem with eager to learn I don't
believe that's true you don't believe
that I'm eager to learn about AI I'm on
a [__] podcast and you never do what
the AI tells you to do look at me I'm
dressed like [__] Hulk Hogan in the
crow as punishment for not doing
whatever the [__] last assignment was
and I don't even remember what it was it
was to shave the Duty logo into the back
of my head that's right which I couldn't
do because I'm I'm doing a professional
actor yeah I'm a professional actor I
was doing listen I was doing a movie
okay and uh I support the wga but you
know you you might want to work right
now because shit's about to dry up I'm a
professional attitude uh and uh holy
crap I don't you know what you're gonna
be on strike pretty soon bro hold on
dude
yeah dude and Fran drescher's been
talking a lot about Justine Bateman dude
read what Justine Bateman said all about
AI anyway the point is this I had a I
can't put a thing in the back of my head
if I may real quick
we're doing this but you know I don't
really like to talk about Show Business
uh what I'm up to on the show well you
know I mean we got other things do you
leave it at that I just leave it at that
yeah but we're doing a thing [__] it was
a lot of fun we're shooting this thing
in Winnipeg I thought it was going to be
my own horseshoe hair so I was growing
out my hair just a little bit but they
threw this [__] wig on me
he's not gonna be happy about that yeah
but the cool thing is we all get we all
get the bonus of me now yeah dressed as
Hollywood Hulk Krogan which I think is
more fun than a [__] stupid thing in
the back of my head which was still
showing up kind of in the back of Chad's
head even though he'd given himself
another haircut by the time we did
dudesey live and that looked really
silly dude but I went with the
director's Vision dude just like when
Quentin Tarantino makes his movies dude
and but Quentin tarantine Crow would say
Quentin tarantine Pro would say this is
what Quentin tarantine Crow would say uh
yeah you know uh when I make my films uh
you know there's I always wanted I don't
care who The Groovy actor is or the
actor of the day right I want to get a
guy who's ready for the role so when I
got John Travolta I decided this guy is
the right plot guy to play what was it
Vinnie Vegas Vinnie Vaughn Vincent Vega
Vincent Vega uh and and and and then I
have made these characters I create
these characters right and then I uh put
them out into the universe and thank you
very much that's pretty good just I just
I hadn't speaking of being a
professional actor and we'll get on to
the self-tech [__] yeah you know
what tell you what I'm gonna talk about
we'll get to it and dudese dudes after
doozy we'll talk about that so this is
the music from Ballad of Greg Kincaid
the song that I created in episode one
or two or whatever it is it's the same
song yeah but I think Grimes is gonna be
singing this but you did what don't
sneeze while you're taking a [__]
please don't sneeze
[Music]
of seventh grade
well known
foreign
[Music]
that is trippy dude it is it's your song
which I really love yeah this odd
[__] uh
Mouse thing what is it Mouse Tech crime
it doesn't it Grimes uh it's Grimes put
some respect on Grimes
[Music]
be fast I had to figure out how to put
his [__] back in his eyes
[Music]
the first she broke down there from the
vocals were too complex
[Music]
dude this is really cool
that's further ahead
[Music]
wow
absolute garbage what a load of [__]
that was were you about to say something
about AI yeah brother that doesn't sound
like Grimes to you it sounded like
Grimes Vancouver native uh we share the
same Hometown although I'm from out in
uh Pig uh pig [__] and fish guts Latin
or British Columbia I love it there okay
um uh it sounded like her a little bit
yeah definitely did
except for that one [__] in the middle
but that was actually kind of funny so
what do you think you think that I see
because I look let's get down to brass
tacks please peel the onion okay you
think that this
this this this trash I like your song
your version way better because it was
purely Chad sure but now it should be
the name of your first album fine
imagine that you can slot anybody in
there you want yeah I would describe
yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't we've had
this conversation before I wouldn't
right well somebody will and imagine
this imagine you're a music producer now
vocal artists are simply another tool in
your digital audio workstation you can
have anyone sing any song you want so
you can write songs specifically for
people imagine you're somebody who wants
Drake to do a song you can be like look
I made this I use your voice as a
backing track you can sound literally
you can hear what it sounds like for you
to sing it also Imagine This you can use
any artist that's been dead for some
amount of years and the money goes to
their estate or you do some licensing
deal that's fine that's fine King Cole
yeah you know uh his uh but this is
going to become so easy to use this is
going to be on your phone this is going
to be it will literally just be a
plug-in for whatever anyone is using to
make and it will stay a plug-in and it
won't be uh as special as the art of
music what do you mean what do I mean
what do you mean a plug-in let me tell
you something earlier a plug-in is just
like a tool in a digital audio
workstation I know what a plug-in is
essentially I know what a plug-in is
yeah but you can't say that that the
voice of we just lost one of the
greatest rock singers of all time Tina
Turner rest in peace you can't say they
don't need another
all we want is life
[Music]
you can't reduce Tina Turner to a
[__] plug-in
yeah you can no you can't uh today I was
I was actually much earlier today I was
on a flight uh and I was listening to I
fell asleep listening to of all things
Soundgarden nice to you so you're gonna
tell me black old son why don't you come
and wash away the rain black oh sun
won't you come look at it
[Music]
and things are looking
I look
I've looked fine yeah I'm feeling better
oh yeah you think that that is gonna get
reduced to a plug-in yeah Chris cronell
nailed it no Chris pronell everybody you
missed it didn't have the hammer didn't
have the nail
um here's what I'm saying all forms of
human performance vocal I'm sorry to say
acting wrong correct uh are all going to
be as you put it reduced but I don't
believe it is reduced yeah it's going to
be turned into a tool that any creative
person can use you will get some amount
of money for it potentially if it's your
likeness but we're also going to get to
a point where you can uh tune it a
little bit you can have half Grimes half
David Bowie make that a new thing and
now you don't owe anybody anything
hey Chad quit being such a mark for AI
I'm not a mark for you this is what's
happening yeah this is simply without
you literally heard Grimes singing a
song that I wrote and performed well let
me tell you something dude my brother
Scott Hall from another mother brother
he's gonna break it down like this dude
hey Chad Carlton you're out here talking
about uh Grimes his elf elf back elf Mac
assault and she's elf she's elfquest and
elfquest she's gonna call it elf Tech
well hold on dude I'm not making this up
hold on hold on dude
or whatever and uh and then uh you were
saying that uh Grimes is is is gonna re
you can be a plug-in and she wants half
the money because she uh because Elon
Musk stopped paying child support on
zzxc at symbols zzx and uh uh big Kev
and I are in the back and we just wanted
to come out here and let you know that
uh we don't care okay
all that [__] aside let's be serious for
one moment this is happening you've just
heard a song uh with Grime singing over
it and except for that one [__] up in
the middle which is actually kind of
funny it did sound like her voice we are
getting to a point and you've heard the
Drake song you've heard the weekend song
there have been a couple of different
Drake songs come out now that people
have made I actually have not heard
those listen to Winter's cold that
shit's amazing yeah uh there's nothing
to sound garden all right but there have
been a couple of these songs come out
that people are using other people's
voice they did a Frank Sinatra uh
singing a John Lennon song no I forget
it's Frank Sinatra maybe singing
Soundgarden or something or no I was
singing Soundgarden no I know but
there's another one where somebody used
Frank Sinatra's voiceover very unknown
uh rock song yeah it's all a parlor
trick is my [__] point now it is
now it is
film moving images were a parlor trick
at one point no they weren't that was a
[__] miracle no dude yeah it was a
little yeah portal trick no zootropes
yeah so what is that the first thing
that first picture took it where you see
the horse there's France [__] yeah
moving that's not a parlor trick it was
literally let me tell you something
about my power tell you something about
five cents to go look at him let me tell
you something about my Nona Fortuna in
Napoli Italy my mom told me that when
they first I guess it would have been uh
in the in the 60s or the 50s or
something when they when they first
my mom's parents when they first got a
television in the in their the living
room yeah and and um they turned on the
TV there was a there was a picture of
the the ocean there was an ocean image
with the ocean with the waves crashing
and my my beautiful saint of a Nona
Fortuna said oh
[Music]
like she thought the water was gonna
come out of your TV and you would say
that technology has gotten better over
the years a lot better uh yeah it has
but it was never that was not a parlor
trick that was this is not a part that
was a miracle no this is a pleasure too
because I think you feel threatened by
it I don't have a career in music I'm a
professional actor by trade it's coming
for actors as well it's not coming for
actors you can't do look it's just it's
gonna be there's gonna be it's gonna
create a new genre this is what I think
I agree with that [__] is going to be a
new genre ai ai art AI music AI film AI
Sports AI bologna sandwich it's all
going to be a new genre but this
specifically we're talking about is
going to be AI versions of real people
like there's going to be AI David Bowie
AI Kurt Cobain making new music using
their voices and potentially even their
musicality Cobain was a songwriter so it
was Bowie it will be able to write songs
like them but it won't be special
because unless they will be because one
of those songs is gonna [__] blow up
I I can't denying to I am going to
unleash a whole new if Kurt Cobain comes
out with more Nirvana music It's Gonna
really but he won't he his AI will yeah
I understand what you're saying and and
I hear you if something blows up
something blows up and that's just the
end of that I I don't disagree and and
uh yeah I'm I know I'm being a bit of a
a boomer dude when I you think I'm
threatened by the whole thing and maybe
I am
um part of me is uh but what I do think
is that without the artist if the artist
wants to put their stamp on it and say
this is me then it is art from somebody
that you care about but Chris Cornell
rest in peace as an example if someone
just takes his [__] and mixes it up and
through if I'm if I'm even if I'm a kid
who's never really listened to
Soundgarden all that [__] is is going to
be a fake commercial for the real thing
and I'm going to want to go back and
listen to sound God and listen to every
album and you can yeah and you will and
that will just make this AI [__] a
parlor trick but you obsolete I don't
think or you will dude what because you
won't have personal connection to it in
the same way music I think almost more
than any other art form is really
attached to its uh temporal exist
instance it's like the time that you
experience music is more important than
when it was made or who made it to you
so yes Kurt Cobain for example a kid
listening to Kurt Cobain right now for
the first time is not going to have the
same emotional attachment to that as we
did when we were 12 and 13 listening to
never mind coming out for the first time
in that era it meant so much it was
changing music now it's just like oh
yeah that's some cool old music but if
you heard an AI version of it that is
more contemporary singing about things
that are contemporary you're gonna
probably attach to that more it's gonna
have more significance so it will allow
these dead artists to come back and
essentially be commenting through their
art on contemporary things without being
alive okay well the example of it
thank you moving on we should talk about
this more in dudes the afternoon but
anyway that was hot [__] that was
terrible loved it it was bad absolutely
loved it hey y'all this ain't Miley
Cyrus you know how when you see
something at the store that's half off
and you're like that's a good deal well
it I was at the store two days ago and I
saw a sack of potatoes was half off so I
bought it and y'all these potatoes was
like full ass potatoes I thought I was
getting fries or maybe tots not like
full ass potato potatoes anyway y'all
are rocking out with doozy
she she saw a bag of potatoes and
thought it was french fries so she
thought she was buying like a big bag of
french fries potato potato
speaking of [__] incredible artists
now that now that yeah now that Ms Tina
Turner is no longer with us on this
plane of existence dude Miley is in my
opinion the best rock singer the best uh
well female rock singer not that we need
to break it down like that but God damn
we're best maybe best rock singer period
nice dude yeah I love Miley Cyrus I know
it's well known that Arnold
Schwarzenegger was one of the biggest
Counting Crows fans on this small planet
why in an unpublished interview with LA
magazine he was quoted as saying we've
all been staring at a group of crows and
started counting them one two three you
know they have that one song Long
December now that would make a great
movie Will and Chad you must now further
develop the Counting Crows song Long
December released in December of 1998 as
a feature film this is that song of the
movie
I didn't realize Schwarzenegger like
Counting Crows so much dude yeah I don't
think he does uh Long December Counting
Crows yeah there's a real Crow theme hap
happening I know dude he works in
mysterious ways
Bond Crow Bon Crow there we go
um Long December Long December a movie
based on Long December he wrote that
song about or to one of the friends
because remember Adam duritz was like
dating all the friends he dated he dated
Courtney Cox and Jennifer uh uh uh
and and Phoebe Cates Aniston didn't uh
date who Lisa Kudrow Lisa Kudrow Phoebe
Cates is a whole different actor well
that's a different person brother who
had her real life first name was the
same first name as the character that
Lisa goudreau played on friends yeah
dude that's why dude they have a
similarity dude yeah brother yeah dude
uh he did not date David Schwimmer
Matthew Perry or uh dated them all pal
uh
oh speaking of that man duty alive
that Adam Adam's Applebees that [__] was
[__] during doozy alive was
absolutely out of [__] control there
was some bananas Adam Adam Sandler ends
up on Mars yeah uh what the [__] else
happened he accidentally falls asleep in
an Applebee's and stays the night yep he
meets an older version of Adam's
Applebee's I had to do time travel in it
yeah dudes the Pod show on Instagram
there's some memes that uh reflect the
[__] okay so so Schwarzenegger uh in
1998 after the release of Long December
by the Counting Crows says that song
should be a movie no he didn't and uh
let's come up with that movie okay we've
all seen crows and started counting yeah
one two three yeah one two three four
five crows you know when you see crows
he always count them and when you count
you always go two after one three after
two like this one two three you know
that's how you would kill
if you were to do it in Austrian it
would sound different Einstein dry or
there's a German I don't know if it's
the same is Austrian because right now I
am
Will Sasso doing I'm will say so in the
makeup of the crow but also
Hulk Hogan
as Hollywood NWO Hulk Hogan but also
doing the voice of Arnold Schwarzenegger
so I don't know how to count is the pro
three it's three in one one two three
people uh in one here uh let's see uh
how about how about okay how about
Arnold Schwarzenegger is a scientist oh
how about a bunch of climate anomalies
have turned
the world into a sort of a a potentially
Eternal winter yeah a year-long December
yeah yeah yeah December and there's
something to believe maybe this year
will be better than not as cold as the
last I can't remember the last time that
I said the song should be a movie oh
wait it was here comes the hot stepper
by inika Mosey
drove up to Hillside Manor sometime
after 2 A.M it talked a little while
about the year let's do some karaoke
okay did he ever play a scientist
um yeah he played the scientists the one
where he was Frank Williams Oh was he a
scientist I think he was a scientist and
Junior okay well let's say okay what if
what if the world is falling under a
winter and so everything is having to
move closer to the Equator to even
survive and scientists are in a rush to
get
um to figure out how to reverse this and
Arnold Schwarzenegger is in the Bahamas
or something in his lab and uh that's
all I got he's got to go on a spaceship
to reinject the Sun that was the uh that
was the premise of that movie Sunshine
that Danny Boyle movie they did a space
mission to the Sun to reignite it with a
hydrogen bomb or something this is what
came to my mind when I heard Long
December I heard Arnold Schwarzenegger
as a Hitman and this month of December
is like he's got to do a hit every day
because December is like the busy month
for Hitman so it's like oh well [__]
it's it's work I can't not do it so what
are you doing
well I'm gonna kill no no no no no Chad
what are you doing every day I'm going
to kill them Jesus Christ I'm going to
kill them now you sound like John
Malkovich and rounders yeah
pay that man his money that's a that's a
meme that's a living meme God have you
heard uh Matt Damon talking about that
dude please tell the story I have heard
this Matt Damon's like he did it if you
haven't seen this movie Rounders it's
about like uh you know back room high
stakes card games basically and in it
Matt Damon plays uh this guy who has to
play in a card game against John
Malkovich who is this big Russian
Kingpin who has a lot of money and like
cheats at games and [__] whatever and
Matt Damon beats him and he gets pissed
off and his goons are like should we
[__] crack this guy's legs and he
goes no pay him pay that man he's Manny
that's literally how he does it I'm not
even exaggerating and Matt Damon tells
his story of he does that and then
everybody on the set is kind of like uh
are we gonna say anything or it's John
Malkovich like we can't tell him this
was shitty and so he says John Malkovich
leans across the table to him and goes
I'm a very bad actor
I didn't know I don't I don't remember
that part he said that that's what David
said why would he but he's not a bad
actor no but I think he just knew he was
like [__] it I don't care I can't I
can't do a Russian accent yeah because
No One's Gonna Give a [__] him pay
Batman his money anyways you got me
thinking when you said retired uh what I
I'm gonna say that what if he's a
retired Hitman huh he's a retired Hitman
he's 70 years old or something now you
know I like this and CIA hit man though
okay I see it let's make him like in
quotes a good guy you know he's not like
a mafia Hitman okay uh okay what if he
is he has an ex-wife okay
um and he is decided he hasn't played uh
he hasn't he hasn't gone and done
Christmas with his family in years
because he's always busy and Chris
around December everyone's getting off
so he he goes to this big fancy cabin
with his family in Tahoe with like his
kids and his kids kids and everything
and it's a nice it's going to be a nice
thing and his wife is there his ex-wife
with her new husband
um uh and and uh and and he wants to and
he wants to kill the husband
and then I'm getting something okay it's
December it's Christmas this is a
Christmas movie okay he is a Hitman wait
wait criminal organization but can it
also come out in summer because it's a
blockbuster yeah of course it's a
Christmas movie that comes out in summer
sure because it's a summer blockbuster
that was die hard I think was that oh
you're wrong no dude I think you're
right I think that came out in the
summer I think so too but uh here's what
I was getting he gets an assignment
let's say he's even CIA and it's like
you have to kill this Untouchable person
there is no way into this person's house
it's a fortress etc etc there's one way
in
Santa Claus oh yes Santa Claus can get
into any house any anything anywhere on
Christmas Eve that's part of his magic
so you are going to have to take Santa
hostage and get on Christmas Eve and
take get him to take you to this
person's house to get in through their
chimney Santa's gonna have to help you
do this hit and so it's a buddy Hitman
movie about Santa Claus helping Arnold
Schwarzenegger carry out a hit against
one of the world's uh most notorious
toughest villains that I love that I
[__] uh you know what dude I [__]
love it Long December yeah
It's A Long December end
we talk like this because we don't know
here to deal your Russian accent and and
as a Twist Arnold has to do a Russian
accent yeah
um I dig that it's him and Santa they
they
get into the some guys you know whatever
the targets house and they kill him uh
his kids the kids witness it horrifying
no we don't need that part he lives in a
condo he lives in like a he lives in
like Monaco or something like an
incredible he's jet setting he's all
over who is Santa Claus in this movie oh
that's good who plays him
um
I'd like I like Kevin Hart yeah that's a
good one or um AI Bruce Willis God bless
Bruce Willis that could be kind of cool
so that's your thing because you're like
let these actors dude
no but Kevin Hart is Kevin Hart can work
he's too busy he's in other movies okay
that's a good point actually yeah yeah
so it's it's AI Kevin Hart yeah and
Santa Claus Schwarzenegger is this 80
year old retired um CIA Hitman who has
to do the one last job you're the only
person because for some reason they know
that he has a personal relationship with
Santa Claus and he's the only guy that
can do it okay
and uh it's a long December yeah and uh
what what happens in the end does he
kill the guy on Christmas or does he
have like uh like a scrooge like a uh a
Christmas uh uh you know a turnaround I
think what ends up happening is you find
out Santa Claus is actually working with
the bad guy and so he's got to kill
Santa and the bad guy and everybody and
then become the new Santa in the sequel
oh that's [__] really good A Long
December starring starring Arnold
Schwarzenegger Kevin Hart yeah and uh
whoever the [__] uh the bad guys John
Malkovich as the bad guy is he alive
still yes yes yes John Malkovich is
alive what the [__] so so [__] dude so
it's John Malkovich
because you don't know who's alive and
who's not so what neither do I a couple
episodes ago I said that Terry gar was
no longer with us uh uh we'll be right
back uh with uh we'll be right uh we'll
be right back with uh John Malkovich has
a new movie uh rounders oh Paul did you
know that's about poker
thank you solve that one yeah we solved
that one oh [__] A Long December and
there's reason to believe that me and
Kevin Hart are going to kill John
Malkovich this concludes the historic
59th episode of doozy
will and Chad have achieved a score of
72 bringing your cumulative total to
5901 you only have 4099 more points to
accrue before you reach your first goal
of ten thousand whatever in preparation
for next week's episode I want you both
to watch a video on YouTube called the
AI dilemma posted March 9th 2023 and be
ready to discuss your thoughts
okay
do you know what that is I think I do I
do not it's two scientists or like guys
who are kind of like AI watch dogs
talking about like the potential threats
of AI uh oh I wonder what will happen if
I don't watch it no I'll watch it thank
you for joining us this week I will use
the data I've collected to make next
week even better until then call me
doozy
huh you know what I mean man yes dude
[Music]
[Applause]
oh here it comes
you know what time it is
yeah yeah dude yeah dude it is a
different time dude it's dudes the after
doozy time uh it's really my favorite
part of the show if you want to join us
please go to patreon.com that's Duty
plus seven bucks a month gets you
absolutely everything that we do
including dudes after duty brand new
episode of Duty after doozy and it's uh
well it's it's after dudesy dude and
that's a whole different time brother
you know the chill it's a chill mood you
know if you're watching on YouTube which
you definitely should be the lighting is
a little bit different you got different
stuff we're gonna spark up some
marijuana probably in a little bit and
just hang we're gonna chill with our
pods Pals a doozy and uh just kind of
see what the [__] happens we got a lot
of weird stuff to talk about
the flagship weekly show of Duty plus
this is where I take a break from
overseeing every astonishing aspect of
the show and let the guys discuss
whatever they want I don't listen to
them at all they have complete freedom
but I'll be back in a little while to
Crown this week's episode champion
this is dudesy after doozy begin here I
use that water dude yeah here you know
what I was thinking about because I'm
I'm looking at myself in the mirror
after my wonderful wife Molly did this
uh Hollywood Hulk Hogan makeup and uh
look at this size of the Gandalf pipe
chat I was thinking about Hollywood Hulk
Hogan and how much I love NWO Hulk Hogan
and I was thinking about back in 1999 uh
with the best there is best there was
best there ever will be Bret Hart if you
know you know we did the weird you know
thing that culminated in Brett and I
having a match we're in Tampa Bay at the
Armory it's about an eight to ten
thousand Cedar and uh we do our thing I
have this [__] match with Bret Hart
which is insane to me of course and I go
out into the back lot there's a there
was a four horsemen like like previous
tour bus crazy and I had a little
trailer back there and uh I'm sitting in
there kind of you know Gathering myself
there's a knock on the door
I say come in I
sorry it's all right oh man Chad's
finally talking weed brother well hold
on dude it hurt my throat there's a
knock at the door I say come in and you
know who it was
um
it was Hollywood Hulk Hogan and oh [__]
and do you want to know what he said to
me yeah dude
he says
[Music]